J'ai une histoire très drôle à vous raconter
aujourd'hui j'étais chez mon dermatologue elle
me dit qu'elle était avec sa petite amie
ils sont arrivés à la conclusion qu'ils
voulaient tous les deux avoir un ménage elle
m'a demandé si je connais quelqu'un je pensais à
toi moi je  Je ne suis PAS un bel homme tu as
un certain type de sex-appeal es-tu
drogué
à part les yeux Olaf non non je je viens d'être
agressé non sucer puis-je avoir des relations sexuelles avec
toi tu es haut de gamme difficile à atteindre c'est
ce qui te rend si bon comment  plusieurs fois l'
avez-vous fait pas plus d'un
mm-hmm l'air très impressionné cela le
rend officiel
je suis votre ho vous ne le croirez pas
nous sommes en demande nous avons un autre client
peut-être plus l'avez-vous déjà fait avant
de savoir  panache ça ha ouais 1977 pendant
une panne d'électricité personne ne pouvait rien voir mais
il y avait encore très agréable peut-être que je
devrais essayer avez-vous une idée de ce qui se
passe à l'intérieur d'un mur
tout le monde veut dire contact ils ont besoin d'amour
ils ont besoin d'affection et dans la mode le savez-
vous  une personne je fais un monde hein
y  es est cette partie de la thérapie quand
vous êtes prêt il y a une certaine femme dans
notre communauté Je n'ai jamais vu un sourire pas
comme ça
alors c'est ce que vous faites allez fort apportez de la
magie au prêt
si vous êtes un proxénète vous devez avoir un  nom
qu'en est-il de Dan bungle c'est un plaisir de
vous rencontrer Dan hey Virgil et Dan soyez le meilleur que
vous pouvez